- My name's Jeff Klaus,
I'm responsible for global
strategy for our ISV customers.
I'm based in Boston.
I've been at AWS just over four years.
My history's been in software,
and my team put this together,
and I'm very happy to
continue and show you
what we can do to help you.
So this is an opportunity
for international ISVs.
We're gonna continue to help
customers with growth paths.
And as we do that, the landscape,
as we've heard at this session,
is continually discussion around AI
and how we continue to look at that as
an opportunity to
continue our growth path.
And when we look at that,
we not only look at it
from a product perspective,
but we're also looking at
what areas, what regions,
what customer types are
we considering with that?
'Cause we have a number
of legacy customers
or continued SaaS customers
that are looking at AI projects
that they can pigeon into a new
region specifically to test.
It might give them a
great opportunity to look
at AI in that type of respect.
We are continuing to grow as well.
We opened five new regions in 2025.
We're gonna continue that growth with
some regions that are new,
that are projected in 2026.
And the one that I wanna talk to you
about that's gotten a lot of attention
is really the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia.
So, KSA for short.
We have detailed demographic information
and data behind the reason
why we're going there.
That information is also available to you
as a customer that would
consider entry in this region.
And that is an area that
we continue to invest in.
And we'll show you the
portfolio that you can consider
when you hear this presentation,
if you wanna consider
that potential journey.
But we know this is not easy.
We know that there are risks.
There's an investment
on the customer's part
to consider this type of movement.
There's certainly competitive landscape.
You're not gonna be the
only one when you land
that has the product that you offer.
There may be some
differentiating advantages,
but you are going into an
area that you might not be,
you're unlikely to be the first.
Certainly, the local
technology advancement
might be different.
There's different client demands,
different client expectations.
And then the other one
that's really complex
is a regulatory environment.
And how does that get transferred?
How do you manage that as
a part of your operations?
So, with that background,
I just had customers asking me about this
for at least a year.
I said, "We've gotta do better at this.
"We've gotta be able to
put something together
"that can continue to answer the questions
"and the objections that
we get from customers
"about navigating this type of path."
And Global Passport was
the name of the solution.
That's the umbrella that will
be guiding this conversation,
but all the components of
that will be within this talk.
So, this is a program that's essentially
a one-on-one program where we come to you
and we essentially give you this advice
from the deep plumbing of AWS.
Re:Invent gives you a little idea
of how vast the scale is of AWS resources.
Part of the challenge there
is finding those experts
who can address those areas
that I mentioned before
that are major challenges.
So, that's the objective
that we're going to review,
and we've done this for just over a year.
We're still only at about 400 customers.
Out of the thousands of
customers that we have,
there are some criteria
that we'll go through
in order to get into this
program, but we're not only--
we're really looking at those next wave
of growth opportunities here
in order to help with that trajectory
into a new region specifically.
This is probably the proudest slide
that I have on here from my team,
is that the customers
that are in this program
that are working through Passport
are growing at twice the rate of customers
that are not in it.
Now, you could say,
"Hey, those are customers
"that are looking to grow."
Yes, they are, but we're facilitating,
accelerating, we're
putting fuel on the fire
and helping to smooth the ROI
to make it as fast as
possible, and guess what?
Those account teams are
telling their peers,
their peers are telling
the other individuals
that they work with, and
it's continuing to work out.
So what is it?
Passport is essentially
four different pillars
that are designed to address those needs
that I mentioned at the beginning.
The first part is strategic planning.
We're gonna go through each of these
in a little more detail.
Next one is technical readiness.
We have some senior people
that have done this before
with customers that
are in 25-plus regions.
We wanna make sure that we
avoid any future mistakes,
and you can learn from their experiences.
And then we have a regulatory
compliance element,
and then we also wanna make
sure that when you land,
wouldn't it be nice for you to have
some pavement path paved there
to be ready for go-to-market
and understand the environment
when you're landing.
So the first piece is strategic planning.
We have three wonderful
partners that we work with.
Think & Grow does the
bulk of these sessions.
They're the OG of partners
that we've worked with here,
and we had a relationship with
Think & Grow prior to this
because they help our customers
with growth opportunities,
and we've also been using Thoughtworks
for some technical deep-dive
challenges with customers,
and then we have EDT for a
public sector specifically.
And what we wanna get out of this
is really to package a plan
for customers to have a
strategy to put together
'cause there were times when
I was asking a customer,
"Why did you just launch in the UAE?"
The response I got was,
"Well, we got one customer
"that said they want our product there,
"and my brother-in-law
happens to live there,
"so it's pretty easy for
me to go make that work."
That's not a strategy for deep
engagement in a new region.
So Think & Grow is made
up of really mature,
some senior operators that have experience
at taking startups into new regions,
and each of these partners
have different skills
that can help you to pave
and build a strategy.
Then what happens is that
strategy gets components
that are listed here.
You can talk about any
one of these components,
and then you can add on
some additional items
if you like what you see.
You can even have them
help you with first hires
in a new region.
You can have them help you
with deeper go-to-market data.
But the program components are really just
kind of understanding the market
fit, how you go to market.
Are you channel? Are you direct?
What's your pricing strategy?
All these considerations.
Now, we've had some very senior customers
that are some of our largest
customers come and say,
"Hey, you know what?
"We want you to evaluate
our existing strategy
"for this next set of
regions that we wanna go in."
So don't think that this
is just for customers
that are emerging or just
starting out in this path.
We've had some other senior groups come
and want us to evaluate what
they're currently doing.
So after that session,
it's about a two-and-a-half-hour session
that we spend time with initially.
There will be a report out
that takes approximately two weeks,
and that report is
something that summarizes
the observations that were
provided during the workshop.
It also gives you a set of recommendations
and kind of a playbook
for that next region,
but it's also the next, next region,
something that you can use as a template
and evaluate for future engagements
and give you that type of confidence
that you've got a third party
that's taking a look at this
and giving you some advice.
We've had customers bring
that to their board.
We've had customers use
this internally and say,
"We're not saying this.
"This team is also saying."
So there's definitely some advantages
to the report outs and the guide
for understanding how this would work.
All right, the next pillar
is really about technical readiness.
We don't want there to be any surprises.
Do you know that our regions,
we price our products differently?
We price our services differently.
We don't have every
service in every region.
We have some senior SAs, as I mentioned,
that have gone through this journey
with a number of customers,
and they come in and
spend an hour with you
to ensure that there
are some best practices
that are transferred.
Think of this as kind of
a well-architected review
for new region expansion, just
to ensure that your footprint
is as tight and as modernized as possible
before we start replicating
it multiple times.
Let's get the cost down as much as we can
before we have to overcome
those cold start costs
to achieve a fast ROI.
There's also security considerations,
performance enhancements.
So this is a session where the
SA, senior SA will go through
and talk about the
opportunities in this domain.
So we wanna make sure
you get the right servers
in that environment
that you typically use.
We wanna make sure that the services
and the features of those services
are available in that region as well.
So that is the goal of the
technical readiness session.
The outputs are essentially to make sure
that you are aware of what's happening,
and we'll go deeper into that
by bringing up a customer,
so you don't have to hear it from me.
We'll bring up a customer
that's gone through this,
and I'm gonna bring up Paul Peterson,
who's the regional
offering manager for Qlik,
and Qlik's had a great growth experience.
I wanna have him talk about
his experience with Passport.
- Thank you.
So just a little bit about Qlik.
So Qlik's been around
for quite a long time.
We've got something like
40,000 customers globally.
A number of product
items in our portfolio,
both client-managed and
SaaS infrastructure.
Gartner, Magic Quadrant
leader in a number of areas.
And we're looking to,
over the last kind of five years, I guess,
I've been with Qlik
for almost seven years,
like everybody, moving to cloud, right?
Moving to SaaS.
So as we move our portfolio to the cloud,
we are having to address our customers'
data sovereignty, residency,
regulatory requirements,
just as Jeff was highlighting, right?
We have hit all of those
in spades, if you will,
on how do we look to expand
and bring our customers
onto our SaaS environment.
So a little bit about what we do.
Our main platform, unlike our competitors,
we have a comprehensive unified platform
where we provide everything
from analytics to AI
to data management,
integration, so on and so forth
on our overall solution.
From our expansion strategy,
this year, in 2025, we've
added five new regions on top.
I think we're now over
between 10 and 15 globally.
We've done the UAE, Israel,
Brazil, and France this year,
as well as expanding our
US government footprint
with a new DoD region.
And in support of that,
we had kind of a base
footprint, if you will,
for each of our regions.
We were trying to reduce
the cost on that environment
for, you know, Jeff had
highlighted a couple things,
like the cold start, you know,
ramping up our customers,
those types of things,
as well as optimizing
the existing footprint
that we have out there.
So we had a number of things
that we had in a backlog
that we were looking to work
our way through already,
but being part of the program
and working with Jeff's team,
you know, we had a number of, I think,
three kind of primary items
that came out of the hopper,
if you will, on that front,
that's helping us reduce the costs
of our overall infrastructure.
So the first one was to move to Carpenter.
This allowed us to adjust our
auto-scaling infrastructure
to make it a little bit more flexible
on what we are able to deploy,
gave us a little bit more options
from the instance type expansion
that we were able to do,
ability to take lowest cost compute
within that environment as well,
and improved our ability
to scale up and scale down,
you know, based on our workloads
and, you know, the ramp period for that.
So you can see here,
as we look to deploy the
Carpenter implementation,
we're looking, you know,
some pretty significant numbers, right?
Saving upwards of $150,000 a month
after we deployed this into
our global infrastructure
across those regions at that time.
The second thing we did was to
move to partial deployments.
We had a standard footprint
that we started with
where we wanted to be able to handle
up to 2,000 tenants in the
infrastructure, and, you know,
that was a pretty hefty
footprint to start with.
You know, we didn't come out of the gate
with customers like that.
That's a ramp, you know,
to get to 2,000 is a decent ramp period.
So this allowed us to
reduce the cost footprint
by deploying a partial
footprint, if you will.
And we have a couple of
really high-cost items
that are in there.
One thing we call our one app
per engine implementation.
This is for customers who have
really, really heavy-duty
analytics workloads.
You know, they're really,
really large instances,
so this gave us the ability
to kind of shut those off
and save a lot on the
compute side on that front.
So that was good.
Another aspect here was
around capacity flags
as part of that deployment as well.
And this, again, allowed us to save
a pretty decent chunk of money
monthly on those deployments.
The third one, which was a
little bit counterintuitive,
but we adjusted the chipset, right?
We moved to AMD from Intel.
That saved a fair bit of
money on that front as well,
approximately $100,000 a month overall
across all of those regions on that front.
The outcome, obviously, we
were looking for cost savings
on that front, and you can
see a big difference here
between our German region
that we rolled out in 2023
versus the UAE one that we
rolled out in April of this year,
an overall 40K a month cost
differential on that front.
And that, ultimately, that is helping me
as I look at additional
regional expansion.
Lowering those costs
gets us more opportunity
to either invest in other
things in the portfolio
or, in our case, we're looking
to expand further in 2026.
We've already announced that
we're gonna go into Canada
in the first half of
next year, and tomorrow,
we'll be announcing that
we're part of the European
Sovereign Cloud Launch
Partner Program as well.
It's giving us the opportunity
to continue to expand
and grow by leveraging the program.
Thank you.
- Awesome, thank you, Paul.
So, there's a great example of
how we take practical examples
from past companies that
have done something like this
and see if that applies to a company
that wants to go on this journey as well.
And meaningful reductions in cost,
at the same time, we're
also trying to grow revenue.
So, you see there's a
great opportunity there.
The next pillar that I wanna talk about
is regarding regulatory compliance.
So, in this area, it's really
just about understanding
and ensuring that the
passport that you have
and the visa that you have is appropriate
when you go to that new region.
There are a number of
different compliance standards.
It also gets deeper if
you're in the medical field
or in the financial field.
So, you might not be aware
that AWS has ex-regulators,
ex-auditors that work for AWS.
They're in a group that, essentially,
is designed to help you to overcome
and to navigate these types of
potholes to ensure that you're aware.
And they're very familiar
with AWS services,
so they're intertwined with
understanding the requirement
and how you can overcome
that with the service.
So, these individuals will come in.
Like I said, the workshop,
you've got the strategy piece.
You just went through the technical part.
We'll bring that technical person in.
We're not gonna have you go around.
All those individuals
and experts come to you
with this bespoke program.
And then the regulatory individuals,
they also come in and they
give you their perspective.
Where do you wanna go?
Here's what to look out for.
We also have tools to ensure
that you can pass regular
audits in this regard, as well.
So, that is the third pillar
and a pretty large piece, as
well, that we wanna remove.
The next piece is around go-to-market.
Wouldn't it be nice to
be able to be confident
when you land in a new arena
what that will look like?
And I often equate this to--
I think most of us have
been into a new airport
for the first time.
You've been to that new airport.
You're tired.
You might be jet-lagged.
You picked up your bags.
You go out through customs.
And then you're in this sea of people.
And you have no idea where to go.
Maybe there's a foreign language.
You can't even read the signs.
You're trying to find the taxi.
You're trying to find,
you know, the shuttle.
Where do you go?
In the distance, you've
got this little sign.
It's got your name on it in the distance.
And you're like, "Oh, my
gosh. That's so awesome.
That person's gonna show me where to go."
I pre-booked that person to help me.
That's what this is.
When you land in Saudi Arabia,
and you wanna work with a local
partner there, guess what?
That partner is someone you can trust,
someone that knows the landscape.
They know the customers and the partners.
So we wanna set you up with
people that know that landscape.
It's strange, when I come
here, I always feel like
somebody wants to sell me something,
whether it's here in the
taxi or going anywhere.
And it's hard to trust them, right?
So you need to work with people you trust,
and that's what this is.
The partner program has
a wealth of capabilities
that can offer you through
Marketplace, the partner network,
and these individuals
understand how to navigate that.
So they use this matrix of
different co-sell activities
in order to help educate the AWS team,
the local team, on your solution,
and kind of build some momentum
and some discipline from how
the best companies operate
because they've operated
and they've seen how those companies work.
So it's things like CRM integration,
scalable motions around co-sell,
and I'm gonna let some of
them speak to you about this.
So what we've done so far
is that we've pieced
together some partners
in different regions that can help you.
They know the landscape, and
as a part of the program,
we help pave that first instance.
We pay for the use and
utilization of those individuals
in order to get that
first set of opportunities
under the covers.
Now, the other exceptional data point here
is that Passport Catalyst customers,
'cause we call this final
pillar Passport Catalyst,
those customers are growing 65% faster
than the regular Passport customers.
So you've got people
that are not in Passport,
and then you've got double
the growth for Passport,
and then you've got 65% higher
for people that are in Catalyst.
So you see there's momentum here
in what we're trying to build,
and that's the value of
where we're taking this.
So I'm gonna have some partners
come and talk to you about what they do,
how they operate with their customers,
and give you some specific
customer examples.
The first is Symbio.
So I'm gonna bring up Justin,
and then he'll bring up Francesca,
and he'll talk to you about his
experience with the program.
- Thank you, Jeff.
Morning, everyone.
Thank you for being here,
my name's Justin Eddy.
I'm the founder of Symbio.
It's good to have you here.
Symbio is a cloud go-to-market agency.
So we specialize in AWS, Co-Sell,
and co-marketing services.
And our goal, as Jeff mentioned,
is to accelerate that journey
to Co-Sell revenue with AWS.
So what we do is we bring
together three services
within the Passport Catalyst program.
Those three services
are here on the slide,
partner marketing services.
So starting with that,
we focus on your joint messaging
and positioning with AWS.
How can we clearly articulate
that better-together narrative
to the AWS customer, to the AWS ecosystem,
so that we know you're
landing that message
with maximum impact?
And then build the content
and the campaigns to tell that
story and drive awareness.
The second is the Co-Sell
enablement services.
This is really driving that
message to the AWS sellers,
as well as to the partner sellers,
to help them work effectively
with AWS sellers in Co-Sell,
help them to understand the best practices
and have the materials and toolkits
to drive Co-Sell opportunities
and joint sales engagements.
The third is the fractional
partner staffing.
So our team provides AWS-enabled PDMs
who can navigate the AWS programs
and the variety of resources
to help partners to unlock and qualify
for these go-to-market
benefits within the program.
And we provide Co-Sell
specialists who help to execute
on joint sales engagements
and to enable best practices
for working with AWS on
specific opportunities
and expanding those.
All three of these kind of come together
in the Catalyst program to
enable this virtuous cycle,
which you see here,
starting with kind of
partner-led co-marketing
driving the content and the messaging
to drive lead acquisition
and pipeline generation.
That really opens the door to
connecting with AWS sellers.
Once you're working with AWS sellers,
you build those
relationships and the trust,
opportunity by opportunity,
seller by seller,
you can expand that relationship
through these best practices
to other accounts, their peers,
other sellers, into
broader sales enablement
and identification of other
accounts and opportunities
that you can work on and
then repeat this cycle.
So all three of these
services come together
to enable that virtuous flywheel effect
of Co-Selling with AWS.
So we have a great example of this today.
I'm excited to have Darktrace,
our mutual customer here,
to talk about a real-world
story about this.
So I would love to
introduce Francesca Bowen,
VP of strategic alliances at Darktrace.
- Thank you, Justin.
And thank you, Jeff.
Well, it's lovely to see everyone.
And I'm really privileged to
be part of this conversation
because we've had an awesome
experience with Passport.
Actually, firstly, with Think
and Grow at the very beginning
and then with Symbio
when we really looked to kind of expand.
So show of hands, who is
not familiar with Darktrace?
Okay, only a few.
Well, that's good
because I love to just
give a bit of a background
on the story and the history
'cause it's a really
interesting organization.
Darktrace was the first to apply AI
to the challenge of
cybersecurity back in 2013.
This is before the big rage of AI
and certainly before we were talking
about AI and cybersecurity.
And so what we do is
we learn the behaviors
of individual customers.
And we are able to, in real
time, to detect and respond
against never-before-seen threats.
That's really, really helpful
for our 10,000-plus customers
but particularly in regulated
industries like manufacturing
which is what we'll talk about today.
So yeah, we'll do a billion
dollars in ARR this next year.
We were listed on the
London Stock Exchange.
We've now been bought out by Thoma Bravo
a big PE firm in the U.S.
And it's been an incredible
journey with AWS.
I'd love to just talk
about the Passport program.
So just again, show of hands,
who is interested in Passport?
Who's part of it today?
Okay, so it might be early
days for some of you.
So what I would say about
Passport is the secret to success
is gonna be intentionality, right?
You've gotta be really intentional
with what you wanna get
out of this program.
And so let's think about
the kind of the challenge
for Darktrace at the time.
As you can hear, we're a
British-born organization.
And so we are managed
by AWS out of the U.K.,
which is awesome.
That's where our dev is.
But ultimately, it means
that all of our resources
is in the U.K. and EMEA from AWS.
And so just naturally, well,
naturally alongside John here
who runs our alliances in EMEA,
we grew very quickly in that region,
but less so in the U.S.,
which again, for our business in general,
didn't make much sense
because ultimately, we
do more of our revenue
out of the Americas.
So we wanted to elevate
the AWS partnership
specifically in North America.
And we wanted to kind of
mature that co-sell mechanism
that can be so awesome, you
know, between our sellers.
So what do we do and how do we do it?
So ultimately, the
Passport Catalyst funded,
as Jess said, the ability to work
with an organization like Symbio.
And that was really awesome
because what happened was
that we were assigned a PDM,
so a Partner Development Manager,
with that kind of AWS-specific skill set.
And they really, and she, Maria,
extended our alliances team
and really helped us to nail down
the better-together messaging.
That is the most important thing
when you're going to market with AWS.
So we think about back to the objective,
ultimately, we were trying to
mature our co-sell efforts.
And so our customer in this
is kind of the AWS seller, right?
So we need to think about
how, in manufacturing,
we decided to choose that industry
because it's less saturated
against things like financial services.
How are we gonna help
the seller sell more AWS
or reduce friction to sale?
Ultimately, leading to more revenue.
And again, for Darktrace,
what we do is we secure organizations,
particularly in regulated industries,
across their entire digital estate.
So if you think about manufacturing,
there's a lot of legacy
operational technology, IT,
and they want to kind
of gain the efficiencies
and benefits from cloud, but
can be slower on the uptake
because of that security challenge.
And so this is where
Darktrace come in, right?
So we make a great
partner to the AWS seller
to really help drive additional revenue
and help the customer
transform towards AWS Cloud.
So with that story, Symbio
built this brilliant
to AWS and through AWS kind of assets
that we still use today,
even after the campaign.
They're absolutely fantastic.
And then ultimately, we package it up
to create a very targeted
marketing campaign
into medium, large size
manufacturing companies in the US.
So what were the results?
They're pretty good.
I was pretty happy.
So, you know, the numbers
speak for themselves,
but I think what I'd like
to highlight is a couple,
well, three things that
got me really excited.
The first one was access
into organizations
that we'd never engaged with before.
In fact, we had meaningful engagement
with 10 of the kind of top
50 manufacturing companies
in America that we had never
meaningfully engaged with.
That's a really big deal, right?
The next thing is procurement.
So I didn't mention, but of course,
we're on AWS Marketplace, right?
And so really interestingly,
we did some pretty sizable deals
with manufacturing
organizations on Marketplace
and, you know, one memory
that I have is an organization
that would have typically
taken three months to procure,
but again, with Marketplace,
we were able to do that in under a month
and that was a very sizable deal.
So we love that.
And then the final one is that number 49.
So as sales and partner
leaders in the room,
I think, you know, we can all build
the best possible programs,
but at the end of the day,
it's really about our seller engagement
between AWS and Darktrace.
So we've got 200 plus reps trained
on the Darktrace side, which is awesome,
but 49 manufacturing sellers at AWS
are thinking about Darktrace
and thinking about how we can help them
sell more of what they want to.
So for me, that was probably
the most exciting thing.
Jeff, thank you so much.
- Super, thank you.
All right.
Awesome, thanks, Francesca.
Yes, great example of how this can work.
And I think the beauty of this
is that you're really focused on,
Symbio can help focus on the process.
Like here are the results,
but the process there is about building
the maturity, the muscle memory
of what does it take to
get these types of results?
And if you can keep
doing that going forward,
that gift is gonna keep on giving.
So it's a fantastic result there.
So I also wanna talk a little bit
about where this is a global program.
We are testing some partners in APJ.
We don't have that fully
baked and ready to offer.
We obviously are showcasing
here that we have North America.
I'm gonna bring up our
partner that we use in EMEA.
And then we're also working
with a partner in the Middle East.
And that APJ is kind of
in progress at the moment.
But a lot of interest there as well.
So what I'm gonna do next
is talk about Connect
and their story, bring up Jonathan,
and then he's gonna bring up Max
to talk about his specific example
of their working relationship.
- First of all, Jeff,
thank you for inviting us
and being such a great sponsor.
And thank you everyone for attending.
My name is Jonathan.
I'm CEO and co-founder at Connect.
A bit about our story, seven
years ago, I was working
for one of the biggest ISVs in Israel,
a lot of hype around it.
And following an investment
by a cloud provider
that we won't mention its name here,
we were tasked to, together
with Yuval, my partner,
we were tasked to build Cloud Alliance.
We didn't know what exactly it is,
what it means, how the impact looks like.
But we understood that
there is a lot of potential
in the scope, so we needed
to double down on it
and really understand what it is.
So this is how Connect was born.
And what we do at Connect,
we support ISVs at all maturity levels,
build their partnership,
business partnership with AWS.
From early stage partners that
need their foundation built,
from the basic programs,
ISV Accelerate, Marketplace,
and so on, to better
together story narrative,
and the executive alignment,
to much more advanced partners
that requires deeper differentiation,
business development,
global business development,
and co-sell at scale.
Since we established the company,
we served more than 200 ISVs.
We're based out of Israel and the UK,
and alongside the professional service
that really provide 360 for all
Cloud Alliance requirements,
we develop our own proprietary
go-to-market platform
called Flow, that besides connecting
and operationalizing all the systems,
also provide a data
layer, an insights layer,
to actually take the best practice
that we developed internally
and expose them to our users.
Regarding our partnership with AWS,
so it's really growing rapidly.
We are in multiple programs,
but of course the most
important one is Catalyst.
We are in the third wave of Catalyst,
served more than 35 ISVs,
generated significant revenue,
and a significant pipeline.
I think that one of the
most important things
that we provide as part of the
program is not only the fish,
but we teach the ISVs how to fish.
If there is a problem or
something that doesn't work,
we dive deep and find the source
to enable them to afterwards
either do it with us after the program
or do it independently.
I want to call to the stage Max,
Senior Director of Global
Partnership at Riskified,
to give his point of view on that.
- Thank you, Johnny.
Thank you, Jeff, for
inviting me to come here
and share the story of Riskified
with both Connect and AWS.
And I'll try and do that in the
next five or so minutes as well.
I wish I was part of the session before,
you know, a year ago,
and we're looking into starting
the partnership with AWS,
but I'm happy I'm here now,
and it's very interesting
to see the perspective
of some of my peers as well.
So for some context,
Riskified is in the fraud
prevention space of e-commerce.
So essentially we work with
the world's largest retailers
in helping them approve more
transactions in a safe manner
and prevent fraud in real time.
So we sit at the checkout
and we help them assess the
risk of those transactions.
And the interesting piece here is that
everything we've built
as a company, right,
since the foundation is on top of AWS.
All of our data is stored in AWS.
We utilize a lot of the microservices
and security mechanisms of AWS.
And so this question of whether or not
we should expand the
relationship with the address
is not necessarily new to Riskified.
But some of the two biggest
challenges I think we had
when we looked at this was,
the first one is we are
targeting very large retailers.
And we were skeptical about
those types of companies
buying multi-million
dollar software or services
through the marketplace, right?
We didn't think that was a thing.
Riskified has very long sales cycles,
very complex, high touch,
and we thought that
someone wouldn't do that
through this channel.
We were wrong.
And the second thing was just
that we didn't know enough
about how to get set up
and where to start, right?
And I think this is kind of the theme
that we've been hearing
across the board as well.
And the advice we received was
you should work with an external company
that is specialized in doing this, right?
That is taking potential
ISVs like yourselves
and bringing them to the marketplace.
And they will know what to do.
If you committed the same
mistake that I did in the past
of trying to figure this out yourself
and read through the documentation,
you probably got lost or
thought this was too complex
and overwhelming.
Honestly, it probably is.
But there is a strategy to it, right?
There is a way of doing it in a smart way
and doing the things that matter first
and then expanding from there.
So we worked with Connect
to try and understand and
kind of bridge those two gaps
and concerns that we had.
And from the first conversation
we had with them, right?
Number one is we, again,
understood that we were wrong
and multimillion dollar contracts
were being signed through the marketplace
and large, large retailers were
utilizing that as a channel.
So that was great, right?
One of our concerns is dealt
with and no longer is there.
The second one is Connect really helped
bring a lot of clarity
to the process for us.
We're a small team and, you know,
we're doing what we're
doing very successfully.
And so we needed to make sure
that if we're putting resources
and time away from what we've been doing,
that it will be the right call.
So they explained to us, right,
all the key milestones and
things that we have to do first
in order to get the flywheel
effect of the marketplace
and, you know, AWS as an ecosystem.
And so that's what we set out to do.
And also, luckily, we had
the support from the program
that Connect had with
AWS and Catalyst, right,
in helping fund for that.
So, again, everything
we were worried about
was no longer a big deal for us.
And this was being funded as well.
So we had nothing to lose but
to try and make this work.
So when we started working with Connect,
we put together very specific deliverables
that we would be working on a time
frame of four to six months.
And that was also very specific
in terms of what Connect
would handle for us
versus what would be required
from Riskified's team,
whether we're just
supporting with information
or we had to be hands-on
part of the process.
Just a few weeks later, right,
we had our technical review done.
We were listed officially
on the marketplace
and, you know, that was great news for us.
But we're just starting that process.
We didn't have a lot
of go-to-market motion.
Shortly after that, right,
we finally got our competency
approved in retail.
Obviously, that's the biggest industry
for someone like Riskified.
And from there, things started to catch up
and it started to get interesting, right?
We were done with all the very important
but a little bit more
bureaucratic and technical steps
that we had to accomplish.
And we did so in probably
around a month and a half.
And we would never have been
able to do that ourselves.
Then from there, we started to participate
in multiple programs, right,
that helped us collect additional funding.
You know, our CMO was very
happy with the amount of MDF
that we were getting as well
and became an ISVA very
shortly during that period.
And once we became an ISVA,
ISVA Accelerate, right,
that's when you have access
to start co-selling with AWS
and you have access to the sales teams.
And, you know, here I heard
the word being intentional
and I completely agree with what you said.
That's the approach that we took as well
in making sure that when we're
pumping the opportunities
through ACE, right, that
we're looking for connecting
or speaking or engaging
with the sales teams,
we were very intentional,
meaning we only submitted
opportunities that were real,
opportunities that we
had context, background,
and we had something to share.
We're not just trying
to be overly optimistic
and do a moonshot through that.
And so when we spoke
with those teams at AWS,
they clearly understood
that we had some footprints.
Some of those opportunities
were existing clients of ours
that were just looking to,
you know, extend a contract
or do an upsell or a cross-sell.
And so that led to them
wanting to speak with us again,
right?
Again, same thing here.
They understood how Riskified's
deal could help them
upsell their AWS services too.
And so our information
was valuable to them.
And just to close off here
with some of the
high-level results, right?
This has been 12 months
or nearly 12 months now
that we finally decided
to start this process.
We have a pipeline of
close to $40 million.
We closed about three to
four deals already this year,
which is a huge win.
Again, our deals are, in
nature, large in size.
And we've accomplished much
more than what we, you know,
thought that we would be able to do,
and we have a lot more
to do now next year.
So in 12 months,
AWS became a hyper-growth
engine for Riskified
that we're super excited
to double down next year.
Thank you very much. Jeff, back to you.
Yeah, that's a great example.
When you talk about anybody
who knows navigating FTR
and navigating ISVA and what
you need to do to reach ISVA,
to do that in around two
months is phenomenal.
That is great testimonial
to how this can accelerate.
And originally, we were taking
customers that were only ISVA
and we're thinking,
"Why are we doing that?
"Let's help some of the customers
that have a great product.
"They still wanna grow.
"They've yet to be mature
in the partner motion.
"Let's help them get there."
So we removed that requirement,
and now any customer,
if you're not a marketplace,
you can also use this
as a springboard to get there.
So how does this work?
We have a nomination process.
You can go through your account manager.
You can even just do a Google
search for AWS Global Passport.
It should come up. You can
nominate yourself there.
And then we have sessions.
We've done these in 22 different cities.
We try to come as close
to you as possible.
We've done them all over the world,
and typically, it's about
once every month and a half.
So schedule that discovery workshop.
You review the action
items from the report
that comes from the partner,
and then there's a
one-hour follow-up session
to identify those next steps.
Like, that's the logistics
of how this works
as we schedule it.
We do have a minimum revenue threshold.
We have gone beyond ISV.
We have gone to some startups
that are below that threshold.
If there's a great growth
story, I'm a sucker for that.
We'll definitely take
that into consideration.
We're looking at success
in the home market.
We certainly want executive sponsorship.
The maturity stages, we've
kind of changed that,
but we certainly want you to be an APN
and know what's expected
'cause it is a commitment.
You do need to be prepared for that path,
but as we've talked, we have
individuals that can help you,
guide you through that path.
Who do I want in these
sessions when we have them?
We typically say, I want
the person who's responsible
for the target in the new region.
Who owns the number to
reach that sales target
in that new area?
That person's gonna really care
about making sure that this plan is solid.
And then at the other side,
I want the person who
pays for that cloud bill.
Who's gonna pay for that new region?
Whose responsibility is it in their budget
to have those increases in
expense and take that risk?
And we often see great debate happening
between these people in these sessions.
There's often a debate
about where do we go first?
We've had large customers
come to us and say,
can you help me force
rank the next three areas
that we wanna consider growing in?
Okay, we've done that.
We have used partners to
get data in some cases,
or we've used some AWS data.
What type of customer are you selling to?
How can we help inform
you to make a decision
to break that tie if there's
a challenge internally?
These are the individuals that we want
in order to have that session.
So this is a summary, this
is what we learned today.
We talked about the strategy pillar.
We talked about technical readiness.
We have a regulatory element as well.
And then we had some great
examples on go-to-market.
'Cause initially, guess what?
Go-to-market is still
our biggest challenge.
When you land in a new region,
you can put an instance up today.
You can put a new instance up.
If you don't have those
technical problems,
you can open up and be available.
But how do you generate sales
and get that motion working?
That's the biggest challenge,
and that's why we are relying
on some great partners
in order to make that happen.
So here's a path to the public site.
If you don't have an
account team covering you,
this is a path to scheduling a workshop.
We do have some operations
people that can help,
and that is how we operate.
So anyway, thank you.
Hope you learned something,
and hopefully this is something
you can take advantage of.
Appreciate it.
(audience applauds)